اذا احتجاجات مستمره منذ اكثر من ثلاثه
اشهر تدق اسس سد المنيع بناه النظام
الايراني لحمايه الهرم وراسه هذا الحصن
يقوم على تشكيلات اساسها الحرس الثوري
والباسيج بدعم من ميليشياتن اخرى البسيج
وهي قوه متطوعه شبه عسكريه تشكلت كمليشيات
شبابيه نهايه سبعينيات القرن الماضي اما
الحرس الثوري فيعدد جيشا مكرسا لحمايه
الحكومات من الاضطرابات الداخليه والهجمات
بالاضافه الى حزب الله الايراني وهي
ميليشيا اكثر تطرفا تدعو الى حكم ديني
كامل وفقا لصحيفه
التي اكدت اعتمادا النظام الايراني كذلك
على الاف المؤيدين ممن وصفاتهم بالمخلصين
لوقفه في حركه الاحتجاجات والتصدي
للمتظرين في الشوارع
وصفت الصحيفه هؤلاء المؤيدين بالبنيه
التحتيه الضيله لكن الصلبه نظرا الى ان
المتشددين ليسوا لديهم مكان يذهبون اليه
مرجحه انقسام في حاله غيابهم ما يؤكد
اعتمادا النظام على هذه الفئات وهو تدني
شعبيه ضم لادن مستوياته فبحسب استطلاعات
راي اجرتها مؤسسه بحثيه غير ربحيه مقرها
هولندا واحد من كل خمسه ايرانيين فقط
يدعمونا النظام الحالي لكن حتى هذا الواحد
من خمسه لا يكافئ مقابل ولائه ولا يكافئ
مقابل هذا الولاء فهذا فهم هؤلاء هؤلاء
ينحدرون غالبا من خلفيات متواضعه اقتصاديه
ومحافظه اجتماعيا يتم اعطائهم امتيازات
ووظائف وكذلك اسلحه الباحثون اكدوا
الباحثون الايرانيون اكدوا ان ايران
تهيئوا شباب من عائلات محافظه الانضمام
الى الباسيج مع تدريب على المبادئ الدينيه
والايديولوجيه المعاديه للغرب في معسكرات
الاطفال وكذلك نوادي الاحياء
[موسيقى]